this was always the day Donald Trump
plan to restart his campaign for
re-election in person but the bigger
issues confronting America continued to
dominate he headed to Dallas as the
country's crisis over race and
inequality rages on his rival for the
White House says the president is
failing this test she's thinking defeat
hate you can only make it hide now when
you give it oxygen when a president
speaks no matter how good or bad he is
people listen and when he speaks and
gives credibility to these races folks
out there he breeze knocks they come out
front of the rocks across America the
images keep on telling the story of the
mood in Virginia a statute dedicated to
the Confederate past was pulled down by
protesters and the modern-day crisis
reinforced by the release of this police
body camera footage showing the arrest
of Derrick Scott in Oklahoma last year
like George Floyd he told police he
couldn't breathe
[Music]
he later died in hospital he suffered a
collapsed lung
the official manner of death is recorded
as unknown it will be in Oklahoma that
Donald Trump will next week hold the
first of those rallies he loves so much
since the lockdown in Tulsa a city that
saw the deadliest race riots in American
history in Dallas
many have questions about his leadership
I believe he is a racist in chief I
believe that he is a white nationalist
white nationalist and has surrounded
himself with the like and so I don't
expect him to do anything other than
what he's doing in the midst of the
protests that followed George Floyd's
death this moment caused uproar one of
those there now says he shouldn't have
been my presence in that moment and in
that environment created a perception of
the military involved in domestic
politics as a commissioned uniformed
officer it was a mistake that I've
learned from and I sincerely hope we all
can learn from it such a statement is
remarkable a sign that these are far
from normal times in America Greg Milam
Sky News Dallas